whoo-hoo-hoo here wasn't had any new The
Avengers
alright well I was in the first part I
don't remember I found myself spoiler
alert I haven't seen it everybody has
seen it everybody
how about cabin in the woods a movie
that Joss producer okay so there's a
couple captain how about a tall house
angel Buffy
fireflies dr. Horrible's sing-along blog
yes sorry you're right
I apologize so the obvious question that
I'm sure you've been asked a thousand
times is how does doing Shakespeare's
original text shot in black and white in
twelve days at your home like doing the
Avengers surprisingly similar we're way
behind and everybody's schedule is the
nightmare and you were just trying to
get it you know just trying to get it
out before they kick us off the location
so your kids chemo my children who are
like can we sleep in our room at some
point right no we're making our because
the little girl's room that they're in
was actually our little girl's room
and it was pink but sadly in this
black-and-white film you'll never know
that alright and whose is that all your
friends in the in the party scenes where
there's a lot of people at the wedding
party scenes were all friends or film
students we didn't really want to open
our house to fans
bless their hearts we thought that might
be a little weird and a little bit so
the the party scene was an actual party
that we threw the party was in the front
the movie was in the back we started
with everybody in the movie and then
gradually through the night we got to
the smaller and smaller bits closer and
closer to the porch with the people who
were still I there and sober enough to
repeat their actions and what about the
neighbors I know usually obviously shot
out in front of the house and the and
the people golfing how did you get them
to stop you know playing through Europe
scenes the golfing is not a problem
mowing and no we couldn't get anybody to
do anything and at least one neighbor
called the cops yeah
during the wedding scene and it was we
were we got Lacs with the parking and
too many people were parking on the
street which we tried to avoid somebody
called the cops they came they said well
clearly you need a permit which we
didn't because it's your house yeah and
so they they said you have to stop and
they left and then we just kept shooting
was it need the wine real yes yes not
that you working tonight it was a real
fight you attractive man well I'm sure a
lot of you know this but the film was
actually made in Josh's house a house
that was designed largely by his wife
and producer of this film who was not up
on the stage so you've all seen Josh's
house is that your crockpot that's in
the kitchen that giant crock-pot would
never show our actual crock-pot very
first it was a stunt crock-pot yes and
and so what was it like to be able to
you know roll out of bed and go to work
it must have been a pleasure
well you just described it you roll out
of bed and needs a mixed action good was
that one good I haven't had tea it was
wonderful and I imagine that there were
certain nights where people just thought
I am NOT driving home I'm staying in the
guest room tonight those are a little of
that I can neither confirm nor deny you
just see random people sleeping on
different couches maybe a floor a corner
is there anybody here that when you
heard that he wanted to do a movie about
Shakespeare that was Shakespeare's text
that you just said nano I'm not gonna do
that
I don't think there's a movie that could
be made that I would say that about I
need work Joss Joss can make a snuff
film I'd be like yeah sure he has
actually he didn't invite you on that
one though
I said yes first okay and then when I
realized how tough it is I tried to
chicken out but no
but this is the way it ought to be when
I when I go to work when I dreamed about
being on TV this was it